intermittent fasting for
serious
weight loss that's the topic for today
now intermittent fasting is the most
important
and most magical thing you can do
for your body but the question is why
what does intermittent fasting do well
number one it actually increases your
white blood cells it strengthens your
immune system it increases stem cells
with your immune system so it can revive
and give you a new immune system if it's
been damaged it powerfully suppresses
inflammation so if you have arthritis
bursitis tendinitis any of the itis is
those are going to go bye-bye it is a
powerful stimulator of something called
autophagy which is the recycling of old
damaged proteins your skin your hair
your nails your organs it is one of the
most powerful stimulators of growth
hormone growth hormone is all about fat
burning it's all about anti-aging and
exercise only will increase growth
hormone by like i don't know 750
fasting can increase growth hormone by 2
000
so why would anyone even hesitate from
doing intermittent fasting it can
increase testosterone by 180 percent it
greatly improves your mood so let's say
you have depression or anxiety or you're
not feeling that great you can bring
your emotions up to a whole new level so
you feel more like yourself i mean that
alone is huge
intermittent fasting helps regrow your
brain cells so your cognitive function
improve
memory concentration
focus it is very very beneficial if not
essential for people with alzheimer's
parkinson's dementia and the best way to
kill cancer cells in the shrink tumors
is fasting there's so many different
epigenetic factors
in relationship to cancer one is that it
helps to recycle
old damaged mitochondria and the reason
why that's really important is because
what causes cancer is damage within the
mitochondria so if you can recycle and
fix all the broken mitochondria you can
really not just prevent cancer but you
can help to
slow it down and so one term related to
that is not called autophagy it's my
topogy but beyond that i think the
biggest and coolest thing that
fasting can do for someone is fix a
broken metabolism so if you have a slow
metabolism it can give you a fast
metabolism if you have this situation
where you can only lose a certain amount
because you hit this set point it can
help bust through that and help you lose
more and more because it fixes insulin
resistance
not to mention diabetes
there's so many people studying this
right now it's very very exciting and
the reason why intermittent fasting
becomes easier as you do it is because
your hunger completely goes away i mean
trying to do any diet if you are hungry
it's just not going to work not having a
big appetite and definitely not craving
just makes it doable and just it makes
it easy now real quick i just wanted to
mention this amazing amazing success
story
of this guy who is completely
depressed suicidal
nothing was going right in his life and
so he decided
to commit suicide and the way he was
going to do it
was he was going to starve himself so he
went to his room laid out on his bed
and stopped eating
for three days
so you can guess what happened after the
second and third day he started feeling
better and better and he no longer had
depression he felt energy he felt better
so his plan backfired and so he got on
the internet and started searching about
fasting and he found that's what he was
missing he found one of my videos we did
an interview and it completely changed
his life around so if you haven't seen
that video i put a link down below
fascinating all right so now all you
need to know is exactly how to do
fasting in a very simple way i'm going
to show you a very gradual way to get
into fasting so you can go as fast or as
slow as you want but i want to make it
very very simple okay now intermittent
fasting is a pattern of eating and not
eating it's not a diet so we want to
combine the ketogenic diet with
fasting in this video we're primarily
going to just cover the fasting part
okay the pattern of eating all right
first thing is starting out worst case
scenario let's say you're doing three
meals a day and three snacks like i was
okay
and at night you're just grazing with
chips and nuts and you just do that
until you go to sleep now realize that
every time you eat you stimulate insulin
so we have
three big spikes of insulin and then we
have also three
kind of mini spikes of insulin because
every time you eat you trigger insulin
so there is just absolutely
zero chance of losing weight with that
pattern of eating so the first thing to
do is just to eliminate the snacks
what you can actually do is change your
snacks to maybe protein or fat
and then push them to the meal
so that way they're no longer a snack
they're part of the meal so the first
step is doing three meals
no snacks now just to make it easier on
yourself you want to add more fat to the
meal to be more satisfied so you can go
longer the goal at this stage is to
start to reduce insulin
and to go longer in between meals that's
your goal because snacking
is deadly now of course if you cut out
the carbs the same time it's going to
make it easier because
carbs drop your blood sugars and then
now you're going to be hungry so if you
combine quito with this it's going to be
really easy all right so we go in the
first stage three meals no snacks you do
that for a few days and what's gonna
happen is you're gonna wake up in the
morning you're not gonna be hungry
anymore and so if you're not hungry
just don't
eat you might want to write that on your
refrigerator it's very very important
because we don't want to eat out of
habit or schedule we want to eat when
our bodies are telling us to eat and so
if you're not hungry guess what your
body is eating but it's eating your own
fat and that is the goal so don't screw
it up by eating and then also now you're
hungry an hour and a half later so the
most important thing at this next phase
is to
take your breakfast and keep pushing it
more towards your lunch to the point
where it becomes your lunch okay so
we're just combining our breakfast and
lunch together and a lot of times my
first meal is my breakfast i'll have
eggs or bacon avocado now you can also
do the
bulletproof coffee just to make it
easier but i find this stage goes pretty
quick you might even be able to jump
into this within the next day because as
soon as you start reducing the frequency
of eating your hunger goes down because
we start making the switch from burning
sugar to burning fat all right so we got
rid of our snacks
we're doing three meals a day we're
adding fat to the meal
and then we're going to skip breakfast
now we're at two meals per day so let's
say for example you eat at noon and then
that's six
that gives you
a fasting pattern of 16 hours okay of
fasting with an eight hour eating window
now when i mention the eating window you
probably are going to be fasting through
that window as well we could add those
hours but for this example we're not
going to add those hours we're only
going to count the point where the last
meal is and then all the way to the next
day to the first meal okay so that
pattern is sixteen and eight and for
convenience you can do twelve and six
you can do eating at one pm to seven or
two to eight
depending on what your schedule is you
can adjust that all right so now you're
at 16 8 you're going to start to see
some amazing results okay the best way
you know it's working is your appetite
goes away okay that's the most important
indicator
not weight loss not even energy
all right if you want to see more
results we bring it to the next stage
and if you can look below in this chart
you're still doing two meals but you're
gonna take these two meals and start
squishing them together okay
so this is where i am at now okay so
i'll do two meals and they're within a
four hour eating window so that gives me
20 hours of fasting that's huge
if you can do 20 hours of fasting you're
gonna see
amazing benefits not just with your
weight with your cognitive function with
your immune system your body even starts
making more antioxidants
your stress goes down i mean it's just
very remarkable all right so at this
stage your pattern is 20 and four and
let's say your meals were between 12
noon and 4
or 1 and 5
or 2 and 6 so just adjust that to your
schedule all right so this is where a
good amount of people pretty much stay
at this level but let's say
you want to take it to the next level
okay and
let's say you're over the age of 50 like
i am i'm 56
and you have a slow metabolism and you
want to have more
i don't know improvement with your brain
for example you want to have less
inflammation with your joints you want
to have a better immune system you want
to speed up the loss of belly fat this
is what you do you go to what's called
omad one meal a day that gives you a
pattern of 23 hours of fasting and one
hour of eating now with this meal you
want it very large you want to make sure
it's nutrient dense but realize that all
the nutritional requirements
actually go down when you do one a meal
a day your body adjusts and so you don't
actually need the quantity of nutrients
because your body becomes very very
efficient and at this stage i always
have to remind people don't eat if
you're not hungry okay just ride the
wave
for some people who are who have a lot
of fat to lose
and they have a slow metabolism
sometimes they're not even hungry in a
given day so what i will tell them is
just go another day fast as long as you
can and some people fast for three days
and they lose a ton of weight and they
feel great so i have a lot of videos on
making this transition but in this video
let's just stop at one meal a day if you
add exercise to this
it's going to be even more deadly
powerful but i just wanted to give you
the overview the picture on how it goes
and you can plug in wherever you want to
plug in go at your own pace make it
easier in yourself but i really want you
to get started so you can personally
experience this for yourself and before
you get started i have some details
about fasting that you need to know
about i put those up right here check
them out